for the degree of Doctor of Philosophy
in mathematics Simon James Clark yep
that's me you might well be wondering
how I got myself in this situation well
lucky few it's all on you chief for the
past four years you've been with me on
my PhD journey from the very beginning
and now we're the very end let's go
graduate
[Music]
[Music]
first of all though I'm not dressed for
the occasion
need to pick up something
[Music]
[Music]
it's unusual for me to be completely
speechless to seeing me in the tire
business right now
[Music]
milady oh my god okay so I picked out
the roads clearly I have got to graduate
first I've got to find mom and dad so I
can I can show them what that boy looks
like and given my back I don't want to
graduate with this change is it okay I
can take you up on stage so we're gonna
have to find a way around me I mean not
a particularly the moment I get this
phd's which is totally happening in like
half an hour
[Music]
[Applause]
Simon James Clark
[Applause]
Thomas Daniel Clem Oh so those of you
who've watched the blog before remember
Tom hello we started at the same time we
finished at the same time we actually
both maybe up second outfits I'm quite a
fan of the Hat actually this tassel is
in my peripheral vision Justin this
attorney had me keep seeing
look who I bumped into down here silly
little hat
he's got all the science brain da but
have you I've already been giving people
electric shocks when we've been taking
pictures so I think I've gained Jedi
powers or all the science is leaking out
[Music]
are you proud of me done I'm very close
to getting a bit weekly I'm starting to
leak myself different way you do that
one toast pops I see a wee bit about
this he is I feel that special because
there's so many people would be stupid
hat
like
[ __ ]
wait a minute even I want me to tell you
about the weather
freelance accessories
[Music]
that's thing about these ceremonies are
the cupcakes do you want a cupcake it's
also a great way of them using up all
the leftover bread from communion
this is time for your speech Oh God
people ask me whether this was an
anti-climax to be honest I feel like
this is just right it kind of feels like
the appropriate end of a couple of years
has really hard
you know and all these people behind me
it had if they did a PhD the same
experience in masters it's a really nice
appropriate closing to the whole thing
I'm very glad you could be here with
are you definitely cool
[Music]
[Applause]
things I can tell you about PhD wrote
[Music]
two very heavy but only on the back
well borrowing an unusual turn of events
I think this is the last time I'm going
to be wearing Oh God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I feel like if there was ever a time to
say a couple of thank-yous it's probably
now of course I want to thank the people
who were there on the day pixal Bell
than my parents without their support
and encouragement and just general love
I never would have been able to finish
just no way I also want to thank the
University of Exeter Chapel Choir and my
really good mate Michael Graham who's
the musical director because Chapel
Cairo is my family in Exeter and it was
such a key part of the past five years
so I really wanted to showcase them in
this video so thank you I can't get a
cab wish you were the family I chose and
thank you for everything that you've
done for me
however alongside all of these people I
want to thank you the audience not just
for watching this video which I hope
you've enjoyed if you did do give it a
like and share it with people who you
think might enjoy it I want to thank you
for being such a key part of the past
four or five years you the audience were
a key part in my PhD the support network
you gave me the encouragement when
things weren't going so well the ability
to express myself creatively and have
such a wonderful response you guys meant
more to me than I think you realize so I
absolutely have to say thank you for
being for making an incredible community
around these PhD blocks which I've made
if somehow this is the first vlog of
mine that you've watched then I'm high
also there's a load more of these but
you might want to watch they'll be a
playlist link in the description all the
vlogs from my time in Exeter doing my
PhD I think you'll enjoy them thank you
again so much for being a part of the
past five years of my life and I hope
you enjoyed the video I'll see you in
the next one
you